[Music]
foreign
it's estimated that over 8 million trees
are chopped down every year to make
pencils
now this company is making them from old
newspapers reducing deforestation in the
process we are suffering from climate
action and the best way is to reduce the
number of trees that are cut for any
purpose we want each and every child in
Kenya who goes to school to use our
pencil and at the same time be able to
plant a tree through our pencil that we
will reduce the number of trees cut will
also provide an option and reduce the
number of wooden pencils in the market
this is how they're made after
newspapers are cut to size graphite is
glued to the paper that's put into a
roller then dried out in the sun
finally they're put through a compressor
sharpened and packaged up
we can address climate change by making
pencils from recycled paper one we
reduce the amount of cheese cut down
when we use recycled pepper number two
we reduce the amount of waste paper that
is damped or burnt that way green
pencils made from recycled paper
contributes also to addressing climate
change
foreign